patricia como está siendo el ambiente en
este día tan importante para el país y
se conocen ya datos de participación
hasta el momento
pues todavía no sabemos datos de
participación exacta pero sí hemos visto
las calles de chile llenas de gente que
han salido de forma masiva a participar
en este proceso histórico para el país
muchas personas que se presentaban en
los
locales de votación desde temprana hora
en una jornada que va a hacer mucho
calor eso también hacía que la gente se
levantara más temprano para acudir a
votar y también recordemos que esta es
la primera elección con voto obligatorio
desde 2012 y eso podría mover a una masa
desconocida de votantes de los que
depende mucho cuál va a ser el resultado
de este histórico día en el país y
patricia personalidades como el
presidente de boris o el ex presidente
piñera ya han depositado su voto qué
mensaje se han dado los políticos al
pueblo chileno ante la incertidumbre por
el resultado
jornada muy republicana hemos visto ya a
varios de los ex presidentes y al propio
presidente votar desde puntarenas como
bien señalaba el presidente piñera
volvió a hablar por primera vez desde
después de abandonar el poder para
manifestar que hoy se tiene la
oportunidad de construir y avanzar hacia
un chile más digno para todos y que
chile necesita más paz social por lo
tanto es un lugar maravilloso en el que
seguir trabajando por su parte el
presidente evo dicho ha sido también muy
enfático en señalar que el mundo tiene
los ojos puestos en chile en este
momento que será un momento histórico
que pertenecerá a la memoria colectiva
de todos y que ha solicitado a los
chilenos a los chilenos que ejerzan su
derecho y su deber a escribir esta
página de la historia del país para pase
lo que pase avanzar en una sociedad con
más justicia más igualdad más democracia
y también más crecimiento y avance para
todos los mensajes de una edad también
del presidente ex presidente lagos que
votó y manifestó que estaría dispuesto a
trabajar a colaborar con el presidente
boris para seguir trabajando en este
ciclo
constitucional que se abrirá a partir
del día 5 de septiembre con
independencia de cuál sea el resultado
habrá que seguir trabajando para
conseguir más igualdad en el país
y patricia tenemos ya alguna noticia o
ha hablado el gobierno sobre qué pasará
tanto si sale el sí como si sale no
precisamente si salen o el gobierno ha
preparado algún movimiento ya
todos los planes están encima de la mesa
para las distintas opciones tanto sea a
pesar de la prueba depende dependerá
también de lo margen en estrecho que
sean los márgenes de de uno u otro una u
otra opción pero existen encima de la
mesa la posibilidad de tanto si sale el
apruebo reformar aquellas partes de la
constitución del texto que han sido más
polémicas como si sale el rechazo
reformar también ya se ha reformado el
actual sistema para reformar la actual
vigente constitución que data de la
dictadura de augusto pinochet y también
para iniciar un nuevo proceso
legislativo como manifestó el presidente
boris en riba elegir de nuevo a
convencionales constituyentes y volver a
escribir otro texto que volvería de
nuevo a ser plebiscitado
para que los chilenos aprobaran su
contenido